hey everyone is stares red sterner sorry
and calm and in this video I want to be
going over our weekly NCLEX question and
don't forget to check out our other free
resources to help you study for in
clicks so let's get started a 55 year
old male patient is ordered by the
physician to take digoxin which is also
called blue moccasin 0.25 milligrams by
mouth daily prior to administering this
medication you will assess what area on
the diagram
okay this question is one of those
hotspot type questions that you may
encounter on the NCLEX exam and for this
particular question we need to click in
the area that we're going to assess
prior to giving the medication call
dioxin also known as an awesome so the
first thing that should be popping in
your head is what is digoxin
well digoxin is a cardiac medication and
acts on the heart is part of the cardiac
glycosides family and digoxin is really
an interesting drug because it has this
positive inotropic effect on the heart
so what does that mean it means that
it's going to cause each heart
contraction to be stronger so when your
heart beat and it squeezes that blood
out that contraction is going to be
stronger so that blood can get out of
that heart muscle and go to the body and
go and do its job
however on the flip side the Jobson also
has this negative quantitative effect
which is going to slow that heart rate
down so you have a slower heart rate
that stronger contraction and this is a
great drug for allowing the heart to
beat more efficiently this medication is
also used in patients with particular
types of heart failure and again what is
heart failure we learned in our in click
review lectures that heart failure is
when that heart muscle has become weak
and when the heart becomes weak it
cannot pump efficiently so that blood
will stay in the heart it can backflow
to the lungs causing respiratory issues
or in extremities and things like that
and what digoxin will hopefully do is it
will slow that heart rate down which
decreases the demands on the heart but
it will also cause that weak muscle to
contract stronger so you hopefully get
decreased amounts of blood pooling in
that heart it's also used in treatment
sometimes of a condition called atrial
fibrillation which is one of those
arrhythmia where the heart rate is
beating you're a
Euler is not being regularly have
decreased blood flow and digoxin can
slow that irregular fast heart rate down
and help it beat more efficiently
now as the nurse prior to giving the
dachshund you always want to assess the
apical pulse for one full minute and in
adults you want to make sure it's at
least sixty beats or greater now next
question you want to ask yourself is
where is this apical pulse located that
is the whole thing whenever you're
looking at that diagram that's what
we're trying to find so the apical pulse
is located also where the point of
maximal impulse is so it will be located
at the apex of the heart now whenever
you're looking at the heart is flipped
upside down the base is up at the top
and the apex is at the bottom and this
is going to be the same listening area
for where you will assess the mitral
valve so let's backtrack and talk about
all the places that we assess on the
chest whenever we're listening to heart
film because when we're listening to
heart sounds what are we doing we're
listening to the closure of those four
valves so we're listening to loved-up s1
and s2 so what are those four valves
were listening to first kind of Alves
we're listening to are called the
semilunar valve and that includes your
aortic valve and your pulmonic valve and
whenever these close that is s2 what you
will be hearing that's the dub part of
love dub then we listen to the
atrioventricular valves which are the
tricuspid and the mitral valves and when
they close you hear s1 which is the love
part now whenever you're assessing your
patient I like to use this mnemonic
because it helps you go in the order of
how they are on the chest all patients
take medicine in the first letter of
each word correlates with that heart
valve so let's look at where each heart
valve is located because we are
theme for where the mitral valve is
located because this is where we're
going to listen to our applicable pulse
okay so the aortic cause all for aortic
is found on the right side of the
sternal border in the second intercostal
space which is right here
the next is the pulmonic valve and this
is found left of the sternal border in
the second intercostal space then you
will go down a little bit and you will
go to the left of the sternal border in
the fourth intercostal space and this is
where you will find the tricuspid valve
and then you will go down just a little
bit to the fifth intercostal space and
you will go to the midco Vick Euler line
which is the middle of where the
clavicle is and this is where you'll
find your mouth troll valve also also
your apical pull so you will listen
there for one full minute and count that
make sure it's at least sixty beats or
minutes and this is where it is located
therefore whenever you're taking the
exam you will click within this area to
determine what the apical pulse would be
before you administer digoxin okay so
that wraps up this NCLEX review question
of the week and don't forget to check
out our other NCLEX review questions and
our other resources as well thank you so
much for watching and don't forget to
subscribe to our channel for more videos